e che è successo ancora trovato un
tunnel
è rimasta oggi dovevamo scappare da una
nuovissima prigione fascia sciascia
sicurezza per questa è anche una storia
roadblock come sempre mettetevi comode
pratiche corno quando vado a mangiare di
tempo subito l'avventura siena e
aspettasse tra le guardie c'è scritto il
dottor rocco è pazzo non ha intenzione
di andare nella sua isola carceraria vi
sono la causa qua c'è un prigioniero
come noi che si nasconde non cercavamo
contrae pare anche lui posso obbligare
il muletto e ve la voglio guidare il
muletto
beh allora non andrai in una prigione
ordinaria dicevo no e come no non so
cosa sta facendo sembra che sia ballando
ma
perché io ti vedo la giunti vedo anche
qua
ma quello non sono io perché io vedo e
divertente giocare con gli amici c'è
qualcuno è uguale a te con la stessa
maglietta la stessa pettinatura che
strano dove comunque
che diventa un detenuto ninja
finita una corretta
non preoccuparti di morire la trinité
bene che meglio preoccupata dal
interessante vediamo cosa dice questa
guardia tranquilli a quanto pare devono
portarci in un'isola in una prigione di
alcatraz
dobbiamo andare in uno dei cerchi per
iniziare la nostra sfida il calice quale
entriamo in questo posso guidare
un prigioniero
volevo solo per obbligare un pochino ma
ora abbiamo solo i due speriamo che
arrivi qualche altro prigioniero così ci
aiuta ok vi piace ogni nuovo outfit
horror norm il cerchietto con i fiori
come questo e poi rosa rosso ma che già
buona del trattato bene ma dove andremo
al atatra riuscivamo a scappare speriamo
di sì ma aspetta una piccola siamo
arrivati poi c'è una guardia signor
pilota c'è scritto siamo qui della
prigione
non si può saltare flavia ragazzi e non
solo dentro la nave guardare posso
abitare posare le porte a sindaco altra
parte ma non c'è niente ma col timone
come si fa a timonare la nave modo
arrivati
a dobbiamo per forza andare in prigione
96 un'altra parte e da questa porta arte
o va dobbiamo controllarvi ok andiamo di
qua
non d'accordo o da questa parte chissà
che cosa ci aspetta in questo film
rumeno avete lasciato un mimino avete
ancora era stato umiliato è
enorme questa questa prigione siamo al
porto tipo mi sembra un po autobus in
partenza tra a 38 secondi
prego doveva lasciarmi da solo non solo
qui questo è logico sul bus che ti posso
aiutare io mi agosto si muova come mi
siedo almeno qui c'è uno sterzo al
volante
il busto è pronto prossimo prossimo
fermato religione
oggi questo
non i prigionieri motore di conoscenti
dottor rocco quello di cui parlava poi
persona giallini ma non vorrà mica fare
degli esperimenti su di noi gli
effettivi sembra un po strano
presto vi stanno aspettando
guarda posso derubare la guardia però
ben 10 succede
a buche
che che è successo mi ha visto
benvenuti nel paradiso dice ho trovati a
e poi 1 capital buon metro
penso che possiamo esplorare quanto è
figo apriti o forse no è bloccato ci
vuole una chiave
ecco perché presto cerchiamo una chiesa
per scappare sociale che cioè la chiave
non credo che le guardie si daranno una
chiave per scappare credo che derubato
una guardia si fa peccato ma
io ho tutto anche parlare con le guardie
e 8 10 punti però e mi ha rubato pure i
soldi o fa non so cosa dobbiamo cercare
cosa dobbiamo fare io continuo a
derubare le guardie perché è divertente
la mia mi ha fatto il taser come ti
chiamano per dare risposta alla bozza
qua se del cibo e lo vede vitale si
prende tutto troppo affetto di pane non
ci posso credere
l'auto riempendo il vassoio di cibo e tu
ti stai perdendo tutto questo da che
senso avevamo dottor rotoli cattivo
dobbiamo sbrigarci aretina
ecco dottor rocco
appare questo è stata trasformata in una
prigione di massima sicurezza ha
quindi sarà difficile strappare lo vede
che tu quello di gigante che fai da te
non lo so
qui c'è lo chef punk
ehi ma questi stanno litigando hai preso
la
ora si picchiano
basti si chiama lui è uno che
lotta per la mossa
si lamentino per fare la lotta
ma non si deve colpire
io mi posso proprio aiuto
forse questo prete antipatico o aiuto
questo nuovo nonno e questo
aiuta un pugno potentissimo guardie
separatevi cosa vuoi fare i baffi
a ok ne hanno subito catturato numerino
ei
andate a pulirvi che attende
sporchissimi andate nelle docce ok di
qua
seguitemi tutto
chissà cosa farà dottor rocco ok queste
sono le docce
lavanderia e aperta e forse poteva
prendere gli asciugamani
ti puoi anche federer che ha detto ok
l'amatissimo
facciamo la doccia ovviamente vestiti
perché giustamente
la vas 35 secondi
ok a tout court a vita cioè 53 per tutte
è di 13 0 fra tv come si fa a prendere
la vita adesso non lo so forse dobbiamo
mangiare qualcuno di questi donut allora
vediamo che hai o forse c'è un panino se
mangi qualcosa ti dà più vita ma riesce
solo le fette di pane non lo so che
cos'è questo diventa così lo chef
prendere gli da mangiare che cosa il tuo
male tenuto nascosto no te l'ho detto
brino e voi dovete fare la lavatrice
ok che libriamo sediamoci o se
raccogliamo in una serra in volta
investita ma solo uno alla volta le
dobbiamo fare la sua beatrice e
dovrebbero lavare
io capisco
tutta questa messa khatri c'e quindi
insistono le lavatrici ok allora
uno investito la volta
ok ho preso il vestito lavato e ora sta
asciugando
tutti ti stai sbrighiamoci sta accadendo
il tempo dice dobbiamo accumulare più
volete possibile
ok in più dei conti mettiamo più monete
si danno
[Musica]
che aspetta è
quanto mai preso toponi thai preso i
miei vestiti puliti e ballo lei non si
fa così non mi rubare vestiti puliti
[Musica]
vincitori 1 1
ora dovete tornare nelle vostre celle
haber è andato di male alla fine abbiamo
solo fatto di vestirli possono stare un
attimo da uno chef prendere una cosa non
mi sa già chi pensa che sia troppo tardi
ha detto no quindi questo dobbiamo
andare
che brutte queste gemme è però
soggettivi alla fine ci fanno scegliere
alla cella se andiamo ora più vicino
all'uscita milan e io direi questo
allora ok siamo qui ma non questa è la
tua
certo a faccia però cliccate ok io sono
più a fianco allora
ok allora e lavoriamo già il nostro
piano per scappare ok io posso un attimo
dopo
non si può
dare in questo momento
ecco sta succedendo qualcosa
ascoltatemi o un piano poter strappare
da qua dice questo personaggio prima
lenny andiamo dal n allora allora tutti
d'accordo che si o no certo che non
appare anche su di lei non c di massima
abbiamo ci fidiamo ci vediamo se in
realtà è una trappola magari una guardia
tra vetro lista dove dobbiamo trovare
qualcosa per rompere la scena un
lucchetto però quando c'è buio
ma lui dov'è ok andate tutti nella
vostra cella rese giannico stavo
prendendo raccogliendo un po di soldi
adesso
[Musica]
è il momento dello show
si è aperta la
guardia sta guardando dall'altra parte
ho preso mesi a scavare un buco nella
terra qui per scappare vediamo in tv
dove è
stato un tunnel
vediamo se riusciamo a scappare da qua
si ritrova la sua mamma guarda in questo
gioco robles ci sono tanti finali
possibili in base alle scelte che si
fanno quindi vediamo che fino alle ci
capiterà
un giorno ha sbagliato ed è finito nella
stanza del capo o no guardi e adesso ci
chiuderanno in una cellula cellula
migliore
cella di isolamento
mi sa che ci hanno rimesso di nuovo
l'ultima volta che proverete a scappare
direi proprio di no guarda ecco turn
over ed offrendo siamo il futuro
apri la prigioniera la rapida scelta
dalle peggiori and roll n cosa gli farà
gli dobbiamo mostrare che cosa che cosa
sapeva lasciamo si provasse a fare
[Musica]
perdonatemi non prendetemi
buongiorno a tutti
ok si sono aperte le celle capiamo
a buongiorno il mio soggetto lemmi ha
imparato la lezione e si unirà a voi un
altro mese o più scorsa gli ha fatto
potrebbe essere pericoloso
e lei mi stai bene mangiare dormire e
obbedire
mangiare e dormire ma da qualcosa
nell'orecchio oggi ha infilzato una
sorta di
microchip
lo sta controllando vedi ok
che dobbiamo fare vai a fare esercizio
trova una via d'uscita abbiamo via
d'uscita
cos'ha fatto a lei mi farà la stessa
cosa noi ci penserà dentro l'orecchio è
una sorta di dispositivo per
controllarci io volevo solo andare a
mangiare da una opzione di andare a
mangiare ma io volevo fidare dei pigri
prigionieri andati a prendere la vostra
colazione
che vanno rare felicissimi devi dirlo
dovere per l'elaborazione
altri soldi
io dico non c'e non spenderò un'altra
non passerò un'altra notte in questa
cella
troviamo una via d'uscita e contro le
telecamere ci sono tutte le camere di
sicurezza che controllerà noi dobbiamo
quindi evitarle perché questo nel
ministro addosso che brutto mi sta
seguendo vista 4 all'angolo parola spia
attento a non farti beccare no no io
sono più altrimenti alla fine
possiamo mi sa che mi ha beccato
mi ha tolto 10 punti o no attento così
farebbe scattare gli allarmi ho trovato
qualcosa non è la fotocamera ma e
tavolara mia martini base di trovare la
mia vita che è successo non lo so allora
qui sembra non esserci niente dopo
queste camera in un passaggio segreto
sopra la scala io però non so dove
finirò non vedere mi piace mi piace il
passaggio segreto mi sta prendendo tutta
la vita aiuto
sono anch'io nel passaggio della ventina
paese by poi tutto telethon trovi una
chiave è chiaro se riusciamo a scappare
con questa cosa qui tu la chiave d'oro
ok proviamo a tornare indietro a passare
dall'altra parte
attento non o farti beccare dare proprio
nonno allora la freccia amanda qua
dietro quindi dobbiamo ritornare
indietro qua qua presso seguimi la
stanza delle armi vedo che diceva di
andare perfetto rai a una mela si non
come acquisto valore l'aumento ma
che fino allora la torcia
ci sono 100 soldi per questo chi non ce
li ho cosa posso prendere con 12 i soldi
ma come non c'è neanche un arma che
possiamo prendere non ha poteri stilato
il gusto in un sacco queste armi
proseguiamo qua c'è una scala
da un no ci vuole il trapano detto che
non troviamo libero con 20 possiamo
prendere una mazza e io non ne ho
abbastanza io sono quindi sui mio 12
quindi niente dobbiamo andarcene nodi
già i siti trovare l'ingresso al
laboratorio
l'oratorio presto spiegati seguì la
freccia ok
ecco siamo nel laboratorio ho trovato
l'entrata del laboratorio ed è pure
aperto
[Applauso]
regione cioè quelli prigionia un
laboratorio voti grande
allora ok e
questo è quel dispositivo che abbiamo
visto prima legge cioè quello che
controlla il cervello ecco che cosa fa
dottor rombo controllo la mente con il
mio dispositivo che è completo tutti i
pensieri degli altri sono miei
lo so se non nuovo venuto un rovetto che
non farò più niente quindi avete capito
lenny vuole installarci quel
quell'aggeggio nelle nostre orecchie
l'eni non alleni forse il dottor patto
troppo non lo so
nemici su nemici mette i funghi sono
bravi li mette i pugni
aiuto aiuto mi ha visto invecchiare qui
da questi devo mangiare una mela
se fosse una grave con mangiando lamela
prima
io sono state davvero sensi tre persone
un minuto
aiuto che non scappare
di capitale
ok vengo comunque ad aiutarti
non mi piace questa pista
ma sono potentissimi questi no sono
morta ma sono risorte bravo 3 mettiamo i
pugni dobbiamo scappare vieni qua dove
siamo dopo ora siamo più toppare qua
allora lui lui lui crediamo ne prendevo
l'emergenza colpisce gli stessi inglesi
dai dai dai sta andando bene
ok non è una volta anche gli altri è
meglio uno alla volta allora 1 e
sconfitto
dai dai dai che ce la facciamo
sono uno che tiene incassato
[Musica]
ok mi trovavo wow quei prigionieri erano
un po pazzi dottor loco deve essere
fermato ok
cosa c'è qui c'è un buco nel muro
iniziamo a scavare
ottima idea l'italiano a scappare presto
scava un tunnel ma forse abbiamo bisogno
di acqui c'è una palla vede i prezzi la
ok abbiamo la pala e iniziamo a scavare
vai
siamo quasi fisico ma quando la via
giusti tasteremo può riuscire a scappare
del tutto
più bello
a proposito di storie avvincenti avete
già preso il mio libro scopriva loro tra
scolari queste scrivetelo nei commenti
si trova all'uscita
scavatore di tunnel ci hanno dato la
medaglia
siamo nelle fognature
retorica primo
forse forse sulla pausa e trova l'uscita
dice
forse ci siamo quasi stai molto attento
ai a svoltare un'icona qua dicono
dell'uscita
vediamo
oppure sarà una trappola c'è una porta a
questa arrivato qualcuno dobbiamo
trovare un posto per nasconderci
prestare
la nostra parola che aspetta forse non
ci hanno visto ancora
però di no ok sbattiamo presto tali
susta il suo posto di lavoro cercando di
risalire che forse siamo al piano di
sopra perché avevo visto che il piano di
sopra c'era l'elicottero all'inizio
c'era scritto no ci ho trovato e come
wow non riuscirete ad andare oltre
progetti per combattere dovrebbe farlo
pure molto forte
no
aiuto tavola ne sta volando ma come
tutte quelle una navicella
capisco che fa mi sta sparando ma come
facciamo a colpirlo simile a tutto il
fatto
[Musica]
no mi spiace molto che partirà oggi
non ho capito quindi dobbiamo salire non
miraggi volevo dire grassi dubbio
battaglie che sui razzi e colpire non
parla
ma perché mi sto imparando
dai appena arrivano i razzies i licei e
tali sono bravo ok
[Musica]
non so se ora possiamo così a roma xiv
ambito riuscendo sicuramente fare
qualcosa
no non sono riuscito ha concluso perché
allontanati e 320 di 500 euro salute
quindi che forse funziona
allora sono i raggi lo colpiscono
vivo dove terrazzo
[Musica]
ok no colpito dal troppo brava
credo che devo colpirlo ancora due volte
e poi ce l'ho fatta però voglio che vai
vai vai perché non ci per uscire da un
prelievo fano si avvicina il razzo
adesso non ci sono più razzi o no e poi
facciamo di avercelo per te c'eravamo
quasi per colpire i nemici ma deve avere
l'accordo
su di lui forse lo usano
aiuto germanico morire ok no sta
sparando delle cose viola aiuta perdendo
la vita che salì su queste rocce testate
su questa roccia è ok ok arrivo ma ho
quasi fatto tutta la vita qui dai mangia
una mela non ce l'hai no io non me ne
vado
io ti aiuto ha detto o
9 lombardi ma porta no
no
e'morto no
aiuto mi canemorto km un cerotto bella
non solo io non ce la farò mai a
bottiglia alla datola
cosa accade dietro l'edificio sia
ancora ancora sei colpi
e momento dio e di scappare da
quest'isola dobbiamo dei quella zattera
libera caccia ma non mi dispiace che vi
sono inoltre il mostro chicago
dai possiamo farcela in questa zattera
non mi sta seguendo vero no non credo
ma scusa adesso devi amare come fai non
riesco a crederci ci siamo riusciti
addio per sempre a questo posto
terribile effetto prigione terribile con
gli e brevetti che dottor loco sono ciao
perché si aspetta adesso o
non è finita qui forse devo andarmi
peggio
vediamo dove si portano queste acque ok
speriamo bene
[Musica]
rifatta la fine uno su dodici
bravissimo a staccare
per vedere i nostri video cliccate su
quello che preferite e ora mi interessa